on a bien compris vous parlez de la
république res publica la chose publique
ça veut dire que tout finalement le
système de la vème république serait à
revoir selon vous parce que vous le
savez très bien il donne énormément de
pouvoir insolent parce que ce n'est pas
ton cela qu'il faudrait revoir soit
laurent vous vous avez la vème
république est mort je vous le dis sipa
ne devrait pas être un scoop et
l'aluminé mortes depuis qu'on l'a
détruite il reste à peu près à 1 tient
discuter de la constitution de 58 donc
quand par exemple en 1992 avait
peut-être d'une le traité de maastricht
la france renonce à sa souveraineté
moi je dirais c'est 100% de la
constitution qui n'existent plus donc on
fait semblant d'avoir une constitution
dix ans à une fois que celui d'un
conseil constitutionnel qui va nous dire
est-ce qu'il ya constitutionnalité des
telle ou telle loi mais ça c'est pour
faire semblant c'est terminé un pays
dispose de sa souveraineté quand il ne
dispose plus d'assez la souveraineté ça
n'est plus un pays donc la france n'est
plus souveraine le nouveau labour quoi
nous sommes souverainiste et la
constitution ne sert plus à rien c'est
un cetain c'est un chiffon de papier
donc je ne repose se propose pas le
retour aller à la vème république en
disant reprenant le texte de départ on
peut imaginer une sixième république qui
ferait sa place à ce que le général de
gaulle appelait sur la fin 202 de son
exercice politique par exemple la
régionalisation la participation ce sont
des façon particulière de faire de la
politique à nouveaux frais c'est-à-dire
quand jacobins mais plutôt aux girondins
en laissant une place importante aux
régions aux communes aux départements au
peuple lui même en disant mais
finalement le talent il n'est pas chez
les gens qui ont fait sciences po et
l'ena mais il est chez les gens qui
travaillent et qui ont des choses à dire
c'est ce qui s'appelle du populisme
quand on a envie d'insulter les gens qui
kiffent son populisme et moi je veux
bien passer pour un populiste parce que
finalement l'alternative c'est populiste
ou populicide il ya ceux qui tuent les
peuples symboliquement métaphoriquement
et puis ceux qui estiment que le peuple
doit être l'épicentre de la politique je
vous le rappelle le gouvernement du
peuple par le peuple pour le peuple